ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء
يا غنماتى يا غنماتى
ما أحلاكي ما أحلاكي
ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء
يا غنماتى يا غنماتى
ما أحلاكي ما أحلاكي
ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء
في مرعاك ماء ماء بين الأعشاب الخضراء
ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء   ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء
من ردد في المرعى ماء؟
أذكر يوما ماء ماء جاء الذئب ماء ماء
كي يخدعكم ماء ماء  يلبس مثل الصوف رداء
ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء
ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء   ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء
من ردد في المرعى ماء؟
ظل الذئب مااء ماء يرعى معكم ماء ماء
كي يأكلكم مااء ماء أو يأكل أحد الأبناء
ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء
ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء   ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء
من ردد في المرعى ماء؟
لكن غنمي ماء ماء كانت أذكى ماء ماء
منه الماكر ماء ماء كشفوا ما خطط  بذكاء
ماااء ماااء ماااء ماااء